at brighton hill community school the
head teacher likes to surprise pupils
with his colorful christmas
outfits what i'm noting is no one else
got the memo about the fancy dress
what he's less cheerful about is
christmas surprises from the department
of education
today he learned many of his pupils
won't now be back to school immediately
after christmas holidays
and they'll need online teaching we'll
make it work
it's just difficult when we're breaking
up tomorrow and then we get these things
dropped on us just before we break up
for christmas holidays
um so we're you know we're going to have
to spend a fair bit of the christmas
holiday working on uh on the plans for
for when we return but we're used to
that now unfortunately
apart from those taking a levels gcses
and vocational exams
all secondary school pupils will study
at home for the first week of school
next term
to help teachers adapt to the new covid
testing program
i think it's better because it just
prevents the possibility of
covert spreading presumably prefer to be
able to come in
definitely just because you've got the
face to face with a teacher but
you can still easily get hold of them
when you're at home
but what a year in education often
setting schools against the government
from grades being decided by an
algorithm to the government you turning
on that decision to heads complaining of
poor communication
now more anxiety over christmas and this
in the week the government threatened
to sue greenwich council for advising
schools to switch to home learning
to reduce the spread of covid a few days
ago you were threatening to sue councils
for seeing a very similar thing
well what we were seeing is we we're
seeing the
opportunity to roll out mass testing
this is the
largest mass tasting program that this
country has
ever seen before but by doing this by
rolling out this mass testing program
throughout secondary schools and
colleges
it means that children are going to be
in the best possible position to
maximize the amount of time that they're
in the classroom
but one senior conservative mp disagrees
with the decision
if we're not careful if we keep having
children out of school we will face an
epidemic of
educational poverty and the groups will
be particularly hurt
our children from disadvantaged uh
backgrounds
every day that their schools are closed
across the country every
it's worth thousands and thousands of
years of lost learning
just one day of national closures the
national education union has described
the decision as a panic
but they feel the government should have
given all children the week off
to give schools time to train staff for
the testing program
the government's saying that volunteers
should do it including parents and
governors
well you're going to need the first week
of next term to get those arrangements
in place
why have they waited until now to make
this announcement is simply
inexplicable it's bad government it
feels like a last-minute lurch in the
face of rising covert cases in this age
group
but also a reminder that 2021 will have
its share
of disruption and restriction jason
farrell sky news